[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con miles de
musulmanes realizaron el último gran
ritual de la peregrinación a la meca
hojas con el lanzamiento de piedras
contra las columnas que simbolizan al
que fueron esterilizados
anteriormente y repartidos por las
autoridades saudíes para evitar
contagios de coronavirus para hablar
sobre este gran acto de fe para los
musulmanes vamos a conversar desde
buenos aires argentina con el imán a
marwan uy bienvenido a france 24 y le
pregunto cuál es el balance que usted
hace en la segunda peregrinación que se
da en pandemia cómo afectan estas
restricciones la manera en que celebran
esta fecha tan importante los musulmanes
buen día hasta la habana y con la pasta
con ustedes en ese contexto obviamente
el año pasado solamente se me permitió a
mí musulmanes hacer apenas son solamente
los residentes de arabia saudita y ese
año aumentó la cantidad a 60.000
personas pero obviamente si lo
comparamos con épocas pre penn de
pandemia solían peregrinar más de dos
millones de musulmanes cada año entonces
solamente afecta mucho al mundo musulmán
porque la peregrinación améica es uno de
los cinco pilares del islam es decir que
es uno de los mandamientos obligatorios
que cada musulmán sea hombre o mujer al
menos una vez en su vida tiene que
cumplir ese mandamiento sin embargo hay
es un mandamiento condicional es decir
que no se aplica no es un deber para
cualquier o para cada musulmán sino que
solamente para los musulmanes que tienen
por ejemplo los recursos económicos para
viajar tienen la salud para peregrinar o
como en este caso si hay una situación
segura para aprender
por ejemplo el mejor ejemplo es la
pandemia entonces en ese contexto no es
una obligación y en ese caso los
musulmanes celebran simbólicamente la
peregrinación desde su lugar desde su
país a la peregrinación bueno estaba
dicho las cifras actuales están muy
lejos de los 25 millones que
peregrinaron en 2019 usted cree que
cuando acabe esta crisis sanitaria
volverán las grandes multitudes o habrá
cambios a largo plazo en estas
peregrinaciones
ojalá creo que seguramente es difícil
prever ahora el futuro la situación en
el futuro pero creo que seguramente la
pandemia dejará sus huellas pero
obviamente si uno incluso compara ahora
el año pasado solamente mil personas y
este año ya 60 mil ojalá que el año
también con el avance de la vacunación
etcétera etcétera que podríamos volver a
la normalidad si ahora ya es el año el
próximo año o tarda algunos años más
esos días sabe mejor
bueno estábamos hablando desde el rito
al inicio de esta crónica del
lanzamiento de piedras de contra las
columnas muy rápidamente para las
personas que no profesan esta fe usted
nos podría hacer una explicación es del
simbolismo y lo que representa para
ustedes claro la meca o la mezquita
ubicada en meta que es la cava es el
lugar más sagrado en el islam y nosotros
consideramos que esa casa es la primera
casa que fue construida y dedicada para
la duración del único dios del ser
supremo y luego consideramos que el
profeta abraham y su hijo ismael y la
esposa del profeta abraham agar hicieron
gran esfuerzos para reconstruir esa casa
que en aquella época no hubo ninguna
civilización en ciudad en esta parte del
desierto entonces cuando hacemos la
peregrinación recordamos conmemoramos en
formas en rituales simbólicos los
sacrificios de la familia abraham por en
las siete vueltas alrededor del américa
la meca significa la unicidad de dios
entonces un monstruo mal gira
constantemente alrededor de la unicidad
de dioses
que él constantemente quiere aplicar en
su vida la unicidad de dios luego
tirando las piedras a un monumento oa un
muro es también un acto simbólico porque
ese nombre es una representación de
satanás nosotros en el islam
consideramos que satanás no es una
entidad física sino que son los malos
impulsos las malas inclinaciones el ego
del ser humano entonces a través de un
acto simbólico la idea es que la persona
el pre divino logra alejar y
derrotar a su propio satanás y son sus
test que su propio mal mal mal dato su
propio ego entonces esos actos tener un
simbolismo con el resumen que el
peregrino quiere purificarse quiere
acercarse a dios y quiere seguir el
ejemplo el modelo del profeta habrá
habla para ser ni su familia en la
establecer o en hacer sacrificios para
la unicidad de dios y mamar joven muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros en
nuestros televidentes sigan en france 24
y en france 24 punto coma
[Música]